Welcome to the presentation
on the Level 2 exponents.
In Level 2 exponents, the only
thing we're going to add to
the mix now is the concept
of a negative exponent.
So we learned already that 2
the third power, well, that
just equals 2 times 2 times 2.
Hopefully, by now, that's
second nature to you,
and that equals 8.
Now I'm going to teach you
what 2 to the negative
third power is.
I know a lot of you are going
to say, oh, no, that's negative
8, but whenever you see
exponents, you always have to
remind yourself, exponents
are not multiplication.
I know there's that temptation
to say, well, 2 times negative
3 is negative 6, so maybe 2 to
the negative third power
is negative 8, but
that's not the case.
And I'll explain in a future
module why we use this
convention, but 2 to the
negative third power, it
turns out, is equivalent to
1/2 to the third power.
So it turns out that the
negative exponent, what it does
is it means to take the inverse
of the base-- we'll call the
number 2 as the base-- and
take that to the positive
version of the exponent.
And 1/2 to the third power?
Well, we already learned that's
1/2 times 1/2 times 1/2,
and that equals 1/8.
So we say 2 to the
negative third power.
That didn't come out right.
2 to the negative third
power is equal to 1/8.
Let's do another one.
Let's say 3 to the
negative 2 power.
Once again, immediately when
we see that negative in the
exponent, the easiest thing to
do is just immediately take
the reciprocal of the base.
So we take 1/3.
And we raise that to
the positive 2 power.
And that's easy enough.
1/3 squared, well,
that's equal to 1/9.
Let's do some more problems.
What if I had 2/3 to the
negative third power?
Once again, just to make it
simple, whenever I see that
negative in the exponent,
I want to get rid of it.
So I immediately take the
reciprocal of the base.
The reciprocal of 2/3 is 3/2,
and I raise that to the
positive third power.
So what changed between the
left and the right side?
The 2/3 I flipped, and
I turned the negative
3 into a positive 3.
And now this just becomes
a Level 1 exponent.
This equals 3/2 times 3/2 times
3/2, and that equals 27/8.
So that's interesting.
2/3 to the negative
3 is equal to 27/8.
Let's do some more.
Let's do 4/7 to the negative 1.
Once again, we have a negative
number in the exponent.
That's the same thing as taking
the reciprocal of the base
and raising it to the
positive exponent.
Well, 7/4 to the 1, any
number to the first power
is just the same number.
It's equal to 7/4.
So when take it to the negative
1 power, all you're essentially
doing is getting the
reciprocal of the number.
Let's do some more problems.
2 to the negative 5.
Once again, we take the
reciprocal of 2, and we say
1/2, and now that can be raised
to the fifth power, and that
equals 1/2 times 1/2 times
1/2 times 1/2 times 1/2,
and that equals 1/32.
Another way we could have
viewed 2 to the negative fifth
is that, 2 to the negative
fifth, we could have said that
equals 1 over 2 to the fifth.
And we know that 2 to the
fifth is 32, so that would've
been the same thing.
Two ways to do it, pretty much
just changing the order of when
you flip versus when you
actually calculate
the exponent.
Let me do two or
three more problems.
And after I write down each of
these problems, you might just
want to pause it and see if you
can do the problem yourself,
and then compare your
answer to mine.
So let's say I had negative 4
to the negative third power.
Immediately, I like to get rid
of the negative in the
exponent, and I know that that
equals minus 1/4 to the third
power, and that equals minus
1/4 times minus 1/4
times minus 1/4.
The negative times a negative
is a positive, but then we're
multiplying that times another
negative, so we get a negative.
1 times 1 times 1 is 1.
4 times 4 is 16 times 4 is 64.
So it equals negative 1/64.
Let's do another problem.
Let me think of a good number.
8/9.
Let's make it negative.
Negative 8/9 to the
negative second power.
Well, once again, that
equals negative 9/8.
Notice, I immediately just took
the reciprocal of the base to
the positive 2 power, and now
that equals negative 9/8
times negative 9/8.
A negative times a negative
is a positive, so we
get 9 times 9 is 81/64.
I think you get the point now.
The only new thing we've
learned, really, is that when
you have a negative exponent,
it's the same thing as taking
the reciprocal of the base
and raising it to the
positive exponent.
Hopefully, that last statement
didn't confuse you more, did
more good than damage, but
I think you're ready to
try some problems now.
Have fun!